the day after the budget and that means
the post-match
analysis this time from the institute
for fiscal studies looking at the state
of public spending
in the next few years and one thing
they've pointed out is well let me show
you
this shows you the change to non-virus
budgets
since march 2020 basically these red
bars show you what happened in the
spending review
last time around we knew there were some
spending cuts coming
around 13 billion pounds a year well on
top of them according to the ifs
you are seeing an extra four billion
pounds of spending cuts as a result of
this budget the treasury says listen
it's difficult to compare
pre-covert with after coving but the ifs
says
if you're going to carry on doing that
spending you need to find extra taxes
to pay for it and that means potentially
higher taxes for the rest of us well
taxes are already going up and in fact
more and more people are paying higher
rates this line here shows you
the percentage of adults who pay higher
rate taxation
and what you can see is as a result of
the measures that we've had in this
budget freezing those personal
allowances dragging more people
into the higher rate of taxation as
their earnings go up just look at that
line it goes
up and up a bit further such that
actually
back in the early 90s it was around four
percent of adults who were paying
that higher rate well look right now or
at least in 2025
26 it's going to be up to 11 percent of
hours a very big increase
indeed and the other concern the ifs had
was about the state of the wider economy
economic growth relatively weak and
according to those obr forecasts the
office of budget responsibility well
the upshot of that is weekly earnings so
our take-home
pay isn't necessarily going up either
this
shows you since the financial crisis how
fast it came down
it was starting to recover but here's
the thing because of weak economic
growth
it's only recovering quite gradually
that's that forecast there that line
going
up and what you can probably see is by
2026 so the end of the forecast horizon
it is still just below where it was
back in 2008 so some people have talked
about a lost decade for economic growth
well here you have
two almost two lost decades for
wage growth